I shall begin.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhu dasa
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So the topic for this evening were the ten perfections.
I'll just read through them.
Generosity, morality and renunciation.
Wisdom, effort and patience.
Honesty, determination, goodwill, and equanimity.
This is one list I never bothered to learn.
So you can see that's a bit too much for one evening.
So what I've chosen is generosity since we're at that time of the year when we give presents and stuff.
So generosity rates highly, you know, in the Buddhist teachings.
if you remember in his own personal story, he went through that great doubt just before, uh, he became, you know, became liberated.
So the great doubt really centered on who was he of all people to try and find the end of suffering.
Yeah.
And as the myth goes, the earth goddess rose and said, he has every right to do this because he has fully, uh, perfected the virtue of generosity.
so basically what gave him that little bit of extra energy as far as i'm concerned is that he knew he was doing it for other people yeah so if you think about uh mount everest you know when uh what's his name uh sherpa tensing and um
edmund hillary got up there uh they are they opened up they opened the gates of everest and now everybody and his dog can get up there so that's the same with the buddha once he discovered this path as he said the gates of the dharma were opened and that business of generosity was what gave him the last little push yeah to go for it
and whenever he's talking to lay people he always starts off with generosity and he points out that even thieves can be generous yeah so after they've stolen a thousand pound from you they can always be generous with it and give it to their mates see so um what we have to distinguish is between what you might call just ordinary generosity and spiritual generosity
So, I mean, at this time of the year, you're giving presents.
So, you know, if you buy a family member, you spend a lot of money on an amazing pair of socks and they send you a scrappy pair of gloves.
Well, you know what they're going to get next Christmas.
So, I mean, it's a sort of generosity, but obviously there's a bit of payback, you know, and it's the same with,
with when you help people you know like if somebody says uh you know come and help with the garden or do some decoration well you're very happy to but you presume that when your garden is doing or you need a bit of decoration somebody else now they'll come back and do it for you you know you're very upset if they don't so that's that's you might call that just just friendly uh generosity
But I think that we get to spiritual generosity, you know, when we're making donations to charities that obviously have nothing to do with us personally.
So, you know, making a donation to things like Oxfam, Médecins Sans Frontières, all those sorts of charities, we're obviously giving something and there's not going to be any personal return for us at all.
now that's a different sort of generosity and we can call it a spiritual generosity so uh it's giving something without any expectation yeah so how do you do it this is the point you see because normally speaking even whether we are aware of it or not there's always a bit of greed in there there's all we're always doing it for some for some uh payback so whenever you're making a donation whether it's
putting money in a box or you're gonna just press a button on the screen uh you know you have to suffuse the heart and mind with that intention you know that this is for uh such and such and i don't expect and i don't want any return right that has to suffuse your mind and then when you press the button when you actually drop the coin or the other or the money into the box
That's what's conditioning you.
And then of course the evil Mara will turn up and whisper in your ear, you truly are a very generous person.
So as soon as you hear that, you say, ah, I saw you Mara, just like the Buddha did, I see you Mara, you didn't fool me this time.
Or he might say something like, that's too much, get some back.
you don't you don't think it's that much see so that's the old stingy mara so as soon as you that comes into your mind uh you note it you see it's there but that wasn't the intention that was not conditioning this is really important yeah remember that the actual conscious uh intention with which you do something is the main conditioning factor right
So just keeping that in mind whenever you're going to give something, even to a friend, even if you're going to help them with decoration, you can still do it as a pure gift, right?
And that has that effect of developing in us just a natural generosity.
So, uh, the question is how do you develop this generosity?
Well, I mean, obviously there's, there's things like compassion, you know, if you feel, um, bad about something or bad about some, some situation, then obviously you're, you're prepared to give also for joy, you know, birthdays, uh, Christmas marriages, you, you give, you, you just give naturally, uh, because you want the other, you want the other persons to have even a greater enjoyment, greater joy.
but these are dependent you might say on those sorts of relationships of one of compassion or joy but if you want if we want to develop a sort of general attitude of generosity uh the real thing to develop is gratitude right
And I don't know whether you've ever done this, but if you make a list of everything you've received in life for which you've not paid, for which was just given to you, uh, it's, you know, it can be a bit overwhelming because you realize it's impossible to pay back what you've been given.
Uh, you're just starting with your parents, even if they were the most awful, terrible people in the world who messed up your life completely.
The fact is,
they fed you enough to keep you alive and in this in this particular lifetime you happen to meet the dharma which is going to liberate you from suffering so even for that you can be grateful yeah and then there's uh i just made a quick list here like society you know the health care you get the social care the education i mean your parents could not have afforded that all that was given because of uh you know because of
the general commitment of the community towards individuals.
Then you've got teachers, you know, just your ordinary teachers through school, your spiritual teachers, all these people have given.
And I mean, especially during school, I bet you never gave anything to your teachers.
I don't remember.
As a teacher, the only thing I ever received was a bottle of wine from one of my students.
Eight years for one bottle of wine.
That was their expression of, I can't have been a very good teacher, that's all.
That's what I put it down to.
then uh your employers you see you have to thank your employers whether you like them or not the point is that they give you work you know and it's through your work you earn money etc etc what about the government see they never do they never do what you want them to do but you know somebody's got to do the dirty work so you have to thank them for that huh
and then there's all the little things little uh things like uh just the gifts of the day uh for instance i was trying to get on the computer at the center this morning and um
um kristin and then uh and then dita you know went out of the way to sort of try to get me on it failed completely of course but the the fact is that they were there just just giving just giving that bit of help so even during the day these little things like opening doors saying you know keep well i hope you're happy and all that all those are just little offerings to us that we don't recognize as generosity
So once you begin to sort of reflect on the amount of stuff we receive for which we don't have to pay anything, we don't even have to say thank you.
I mean, if you think about the dentist, did you walk out of the dentist saying thank you?
You know, like you sometimes forget that, you know, that they've actually given you a service.
so uh if you if you just make a list of all the things that you've received in this life then of course there is this you know that is this unrequited desire to repay and of course you can't repay and and i doubt most of these people that i've mentioned would want you to repay but it it invites you to really uh develop your own um generosity
Now, finally, the reason for it, of course, is because it's part of the spiritual path.
And the reason for that is, wait till I find my notes, here somewhere.
Yeah.
And so one of the perfections is this generosity, supported by gratitude, which isn't listed, shall we say it's presumed.
But the other factor that comes in now is renunciation, just the natural renunciation.
And what we mean by renunciation is what is not feeding our desire to indulge our desires.
so every time we give something away some some some of our wealth or some of our time we're actually renouncing something right and that process of renunciation is letting go of all that greed and all the greed and everything that comes from acquisitiveness which is the manifestation of delusion right so the more generous we are the more we're undermining that sense of delusion
and that and that will eventually according to the commentaries unfortunately it doesn't actually say this the scriptures but but you can see the logic of it just by exercising generosity that in itself is a path to liberation right
so you can see that uh there's a lovely little virtuous circle here of uh gratitude generosity and renunciation which as it were just spirals us it twirls us up towards nibana
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that I have not caused confusion and that by your devotions of generosity, you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.